anémone je te ferai pas l'affront de te
parler des césars parce qu'on a eu tant
par les 168 fois depuis un mois ses
parents - attendent après 15
oui oui on va parler d'autre chose alors
plus avec ton copain la cheville césar
s'appelle christian roth et ganic et là
tu les a rencontrés après un grand flic
une dépression mais non mais j'ai
commencé les résidents les rencontrer
quand on a fait une passe ensemble
avignon et puis je les ai revus un
moment où effectivement j'étais mal et
où j'aurais dit non ça a l'air bien ce
qui nous fait bien rire de vous amuser
plus que moi et
et alors pourquoi voudriez pas que j'ai
dû à bout et
nous avons donc sans gêne vedette s'est
tous dit je m'embête d'accord avec vous
ouais ouais et bien dans notre course et
c'est l'atelier comment ça commence le
d'ordre visuel ou ses pensées oui c'est
votre premier est la troisième femme à
quoi baby boom
non c'est terrible ça parle de 10,1 pas
le détail mais là c'est moins terrible
que ça peut être est ce que il est clair
qu'elle espérait j'espérais que ça
existait mais bon c'est l'histoire est
alors en fait pas du tout une
description de certains titres aux
enfants de rester caché ton temps du
punch et lorbek et tout et qui finit par
adopter un tout petit point voilà pour
aller jusqu'au bout de la relation du
couple était enfant comment ils vont
encore
alonso ravit pas la bonne je suis trompé
j'ai acheté tous d'y placer j'ai pas eu
le temps d'aller retrouver avec un an
les enfants en polyester bon alors
plongé de faire un questionnaire donc
faire spécial pour toi en te jure
longtemps enfouis
je vais te donner un exemple je te
mettrai pas la team pour ce match peut
dater la magie va je sais que tu vas
voir c'est très gentil première question
mais vraiment la question qu'ont type
est ce que tu préfères trompé ajoute
amer mais j'aime les goûts bon voilà
déjà trouvé la question qu'ont par
définition c'est celle à laquelle on ne
peut pas répondre sur moi j'ai dit je
répondu ouais deuxième question qui
compte c'est là tu verras que tu pourras
pas dire les deux est-ce que tu préfère
vivre disant très très très très riche
vraiment avec tout ce que tu veux j'ai
des 747 et enfin voilà alors son temps
pauvre s'entend pas avec moi je suis pas
super super évoquait alors troisième
question qu'on est ce que tu serais
prête à mourir là maintenant ça tu meurs
juste juste après la première tumeur
pour que un million de petits éthiopien
puisse survivre à ces quand même
s'adresse à régler les questions ça
pourrait s'appeler question cornette
incident a mis en place qu'est ce tu
préfères à l'ept de courage ils
m'adorent une heure
le comique que c'est une réponse alors
des petits enfants ses deux
petits-enfants et jacob
imagine tu as plus de pognon t'as plus
rien leur donner à manger sont vraiment
je vais les faire dans la province nord
qui sait dire que ça alimente ces
pauvres enfants pour les échanger est ce
que tu es vendre de la drogue à la
sortie des écoles of the day we pour que
les enfants puissent surveiller parce
que tu le ferais ça c'est la question
qu'ont par excellence non je préfère les
vendre par les politiques pour qui a qui
trouvent tue le plus de circonstances
atténuantes staline hitler ou polpot ou
alors qu staline et hitler que je
préfère c'est quand même des contamines
je connais pas très bien je choisir
entre pierre et hyper mal de grève du
nickel disons que ces trois dictateurs
lequel tu excuses le plus d'épreuves
staline hitler au pôle paul la nasa mais
moi je vous dis oui mais qui sont à mon
goût liens que les problèmes tu leur
parles
j'étais stupide bien ce que ça veut dire
qu'on alimente au cou marques pas tu
penses que c'est des psychopathes et
qu'ils ont des circonstances atténuantes
je vous dis que les gens permet de voir
des gens trouvent ça bizarre alami moi
j'aurais dit paul tôt parce que ça
semble pas
je considère à l'époque sa tâche est
sorti la baule écrit en gras bon alors
je continue
quelle race répercutent les jaunes les
blancs les noirs ou les rouges qu'est-ce
que tu préfèrerais être sourde muette
aveugle première solution
ou alors avoir les quatre membres coupés
à ras moi je la porterai muette aveugle
première solution 2e et 4e mon combat
c'est que tu peux quand même regarder la
télé tu peux regarder sabatier sacré
écoute je ne sais pas là tu vois je
deviens j'aimerais entendre comme on
verra maintenant une stratégie
différente ou alors maintenant tu es
seul seul dans un refuge de montagne
perdu à huit jours de marche de 2 du
premier être vivant
1 et puis tu as envie de faire l'amour
c'est pas moi tes dents se refuse à
effet et alors imagine bien à ce
moment-là qu'est ce que tu préférerais
faire l'amour avec une femme avec une
personne du même sexe que toi qu'aucune
fabrice abriel s'est amusé à falla ou
alors se masturber
[Musique]
oui c'est gros s'avère assez consternant
[Rires]
japon du but avec à écouter non non non
alors canon si tu devais vraiment
toujours pas resté dans le refuge était
avec un très bon ami cette fois et y
meurent de froid est-ce que tu commences
là et tout raide mais l'étoile est-ce
que tu veux qu'on serait par contre pas
manger le doigt où les jours rien à
bouffer tout ce qu'on a c'est comment ce
bar du jambon ben quoi
moi je commençais par la gym pas rajouté
pour coter très bien et dans la pièce
marie à oui d'accord je suis son mari
cher monsieur
oui je peux vous dire que c'est pas
facile les corrections de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus